في المنطقة ، فإن التأكد
من خروجهم من هناك
يمكن أن يعرض كل شيء
للخطر بالفعل أعضاء الطاقم ويعرض أنفسهم للخطر ،
لذلك
ينتقل فريق Spacex
لمحاولة إبعادهم
حتى يتمكنوا من استعادة النسخ الاحتياطي نحو الكبسولة بأمان.
مرتبك ،
اقترب منه
وهناك يمكنك رؤية اثنين من
أعضاء فريق التعافي
من العش ، نعم ، لذلك هذا هو
العش في الخلفية هناك ذئب التنين
وهناك يمكننا أن نرى مسعى التنين
يتم وضعه بعناية
في عش التعافي في الأعلى  من go
navigator
dragon spacex مرحبًا بك على متن
سفينة الاسترداد
وهناك نرى التنين يتحرك للأمام
بسلاسة مثل تسلا ، أود أن أقول
إنها لقطة مثيرة للاهتمام لتنين
يقف على أهبة الاستعداد للذهاب للقبعة
الجانبية ونرى الفتحة مفتوحة
الآن مفتوحة عند  12 59
مساءً واه هو فقط لضمان
بقاء بوب ودوج آمنين
كما قلنا هنا لدينا وجهة نظرنا الأولى
لمايكل ونود فقط أن
نكرر نوعًا ما  في بوب قال وأضف
أي شخص لمسه ،
يجب أن تأخذ لحظة للاعتزاز بهذا فقط
يمكنهم الاحتفال مع بعضهم البعض
، وشكرًا جزيلاً على هذه
الكلمات اللطيفة ونتمنى لك جميعًا رحلة آمنة إلى
المنزل ويبدو أننا "
لقد أخرجناه ، لقد جعلناه جالسًا